comes now the Music Awards adhere to
present them as one of our brightest
musical lights another young lady who
started among this as a child and has
grown into a lovely and gracious actress
wife and mother
ladies and gentlemen Miss Catherine
Grayson
Thank You Catherine you and Elizabeth
Taylor at the same studio aren't you yes
we are huh
you started several years ago she a
little later and to me a very
interesting thing in both your careers
but in all that time
Montgomery doesn't look a day older I
didn't say anything yes I was rather
hoping you were but all right all right
miss Grayson here to present the music
wall for the outstanding achievement in
music in connection with motion pictures
the best original song battles and bows
for every man there's a woman
it's magic this is the moment woody the
woodpecker saw Jane Livingston and ray
Evans Bucky and boy
best scarring of a musical picture
Easter Parade metro-goldwyn-mayer by
Johnny green and Roger V's the emperor
walls paramount by Victor Yeung the
pirate metro-goldwyn-mayer by Lenny
hatin romance on the high seas Michael
Curtiz productions Warner Brothers by
Ray hind or when my baby smiles at me
20th Century Fox by Alfred Newman Johnny
green and Roger
Eden's our Easter Parade network over
there mr. Johnny green reception board
for both winners
and now I'm sorry best musical score of
a dramatic or comedy picture Hamlet
J Arthur rank to city's film universal
international British by William Walton
Joan of Arc Sierra pictures RK l radio
by Hugo freed Harper
Johnny Belinda Warner Brothers by Mack
Steiner red shoes J Arthur rank archers
eagle lion British by Brian is Dale the
steak pit 20th Century Fox by Alfred
Newman Brian ease Dale for red shoes
junior rank our shoe diva lion British
Susan Hayward
thank you thank you very much captain
Grayson